I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hey, you guys!
What's going on? How are ya? Wow, Angela, you're bringing the energy today. I just played an hour of tennis. So you're amped up. I'm like, someone throw a ball at me, I'm going to hit it, I'm going to do something with it. She's in her tennis uniform, so she really is ready.
She's in uniform. What is it? Tennis clothes? Outfit? I mean, you know, I'm not on a team. No, I guess that's true. That's true. I would wear a tennis uniform, I mean, sign me up.
Did you notice that all the men during the U.S. Open were wearing kind of the same tennis shirt, it was like a gray, burgundy thing. There was lots of burgundy and pink, and kind of a modern neckline. It reminded me of the shirts from Star Trek. Yeah. It felt very Trekkie to me. Very Trekkie. Look at you with a sci-fi reference.
I know, and tennis. What? Am I becoming you? Am I going to come in a tennis outfit next week? Oh, I hope so, maybe. Well today, we are talking about viewing party. It is season seven, episode eight, written by John Vidi and directed by Ken Whittingham. New writer alert, John Vidi.
He came to us after writing for The Simpsons and King of the Hill and was nominated for an Emmy Award for writing episodes of The Larry Sanders Show and he also wrote the Angry Birds movie, which is a favorite of my kids. My kids love that movie. Yeah, I love it too. He was new for this season and he wrote viewing party. Would you like a summary? So much.
Okay. Aaron and Gabe host a glee viewing party, but Michael's hatred toward Gabe threatens to ruin the evening. He is in such poor form. Michael is like a little kid. Andy has an adverse reaction after ingesting wine and crushed seahorses. Meanwhile, Jim and Pam are conflicted to discover that the key to soothing a crying sissy is Dwight.
Yeah, and they're going to interrupt part of the punch card action. Yes, I was going to say Angela spends a large portion of the evening nudy in a car. Fake nudy. I was going to ask you what you really had on when we get there. Well, fast fact number one was a fan question from Sarah M. and Harrisburg, Pennsylvania. Why did they pick Glee as the show to watch for the viewing party? I'm curious about that too. Do you know the answer?
Well, at the time Glee was, I believe it was, the highest rated scripted show of any network. And supposedly at the 2010 Emmy Awards, the office producers and writers were seated near the folks from Glee. And Paul Lieberstein told me that during the commercial breaks, he started chatting up one of the showrunners from Glee, Brad Falczyk. And Paul pitched this idea to him at the Emmy Awards. This idea of the folks from the office having a Glee viewing party. And Brad liked it.
He loved it. He said, I give my blessing. Amazing. Well, it wasn't that easy because, you know, Glee was on Fox, it was on NBC. The suits got involved. They did. Mm-hmm. Randy had a lot to say about how difficult it was to pull this off.
I bet there are a bunch of fun stoppers. Yeah. We had a couple of fan questions. Natalie Vee from Winnipeg asked, is there a process for asking one network to shoot an episode that promotes another network? And Leah Roberts from Downington, Pennsylvania said, did you have to get special rights to use the Glee content in your episode? I'd love to know the story behind all of this.
Well, Randy told us that the folks at Fox approved this episode, but they really pulled back on the amount of footage we could use. We couldn't run any unaired clips from Glee. We could only use clips from older shows that had already aired, but that kind of went against our idea that we had all gathered to watch this brand new episode. So we had to kind of, like, you know, scoochie, scoochie around it. Kind of make it work. Like, if you notice, there's very few clips.
That's also because it was very expensive. They had to pay large fees to any performer, writer, or director credited in the clip. Remember, that's what happened with the banker and ended up being a really expensive episode. They also had to pay any music licensing fees. So Randy said, we managed to go ahead with it. And what we did was, if you notice, a lot of times our characters are describing what they're seeing and you just see, like, a flash of a Glee character on the screen, but you don't really gather any plot from the actual clips.
So that's how we did it. Well, I think it was short-sighted on the suits. I do. Because guess what? Had they put some of their clips in our show, it would have been such a huge buzz. It would have driven more people to Glee. I don't think they needed more people to be driven to Glee, is their point. They're like, we already have a larger viewing audience than you.
They're like, we don't need you guys. They're like, here's a few puny clips. You're welcome. Yeah. It's like my friend, her honeymoon was in Hawaii and she kept thinking she'd get free stuff if she said she was on her honeymoon and they were literally like, take a number. Yeah. You and everyone else.
All right. Are you ready for FastFact number two? Yeah. This is a fan question from Fabie in New Hampshire. Was this episode filmed at someone's apartment and if so, who's was it? Well, Faye, it was not. This entire interior location, Gabe's apartment, was built by our crew, designed by Michael Gallenberg, built by our construction head, Tim James, and then decorated by our set decorating
team headed by Steve Rothstein. I mean, what a phenomenal job. I know. It was so well done. We're going to get to this in later seasons, but I felt the same way in Oscar's apartment. They built the whole thing. Well, I guess this was a really big endeavor because they had to build multiple connecting rooms as well as a drop ceiling with a ceiling fan in the kitchen.
Because when Michael tosses the pizza dough, that was scripted that it would hit the fan. So they had to really figure that out. Because imagine this apartment being built inside like an aircraft hanger. Yeah. Like the vast and tall the ceilings are in a studio. Yeah. They built this on our warehouse set. The exterior, however, was real.
You know, when Michael goes outside and he's messing with the cable box and then Pam meets Angela at the car, we filmed that on location at an apartment building in Sherman Oaks. We had one evening. Hmm. Are you ready for FASPEC number three? I am. FASPEC number three is that James Carey shared all of the call sheets with me for this episode and you know I love a call sheet.
Oh, no, you do. That's so much information. You get so excited. So much. It's just a chart of so many times and so many moving parts, your brain's like buzzing. Oh, yeah. I don't even want to look at it. They tell you what time sunset is.
Yeah. They tell you, you know, the weather of the day, all kinds of things. Well, these call sheets reminded me that while shooting this episode, this viewing party episode, we were also having the nepotism premiere viewing party as a cast. It was Thursday, September 23rd and as a result, the next day we had a later call time of 1.30 p.m. so that we could all stay up and watch. Oh, that's so fun. Isn't that so cool?
And it worked out perfectly because that Friday night was the night that we had to shoot all of the stuff outside in the evening. I loved our cast viewing parties. They were so fun. I know. I also just love that we were seven years into this show and we were still so excited to get together and watch an episode together. Yeah.
And this wasn't like, I feel like we should say, this wasn't one of those like publicity viewing parties. No, no. This wasn't... Someone would volunteer to host. We did it often. It was a tradition with our cast starting from the very beginning. We had so many photos of viewing parties for our book that we couldn't even include because
we ran out of space. People ask us a lot. Was there anything that you didn't get to talk about in your book? And more depth. Yeah. And for me, it's always the viewing parties. We couldn't figure out where to put them. Yeah.
Because they were just such a big part of, I think, what, I don't know, what made us feel like a family. I'll never forget the one I hosted. I did not have enough places for people to sit. I had that one couch everyone gets from Ikea. What is it? Ektorp or whatever. You know what I mean?
Sounds about right. And so a lot of people had to sit on the floor. And I have this great picture of like, you know, Steve and Mindy on the floor and everyone, I ordered pizza and I love it. Steve always took the floor. He did. We did get one picture in the book. We're talking about our book, The Office BFF, which, by the way, we are signing copies
of right now. Yes, because we're going to have them as part of a really fun holiday bundle on OfficeLadies.com. Yeah. But there is one picture in there of a viewing party and it was at my house and Steve is on the floor. Yeah. I'm going to post the one at my place. Yeah.
Yeah. You should. I'll put it. Yeah. Well, listen, that's all I've got. Should we take a break and then come back and break down this episode? Yes. I have some fun stuff.
Me too. All right, we are back. Gabe is going to arrive to work and there's no one in the bullpen. Aaron rushes out and says, they got the Scranton Strangler. There's a chase. And everyone is back in the annex around Toby's desk. Did you notice? Who isn't there?
Who isn't there? We never watch videos at Toby's desk. It's always at Oscar's desk. Well, what's crazy is in the script, it said we were all gathered around Kelly's desk, but we must have changed it because we're at Toby's desk and he's not there. Dwight says he doesn't think these kind of chases should be televised because it will only encourage copycats. Angela says, just say copies.
Why do you have to drag cats into this? That got a laugh at the table read. And it's interesting, because when I think back to these episodes, I remember the table reads. Yeah. And if something got a laugh, you knew it was going to make it in. So I was like, oh, I know I'm going to have that cat line. Well, we're watching all this footage and I asked Randy, how did we get this footage?
He said that the footage of the standoff was a real standoff. What? Yeah. That was like a real thing that happened on the news. Are you allowed to do that? I don't know. We borrowed it. We got that from the actual WBRE, the local NBC station in Scranton.
So that was an actual standoff that happened in Scranton and ran on the local news. Yeah. Wow. But then we did film all of the car chase stuff ourselves. We used rented police cars, precision drivers, and we added the voiceover of the newscaster, obviously. And Randy was really bummed. He couldn't find any information on who did that voiceover.
He really looked for it. And then what really made me laugh was when the one single cop car goes down our street because we all run, we realize it's coming by us, the chase. That street is a dead end. I know. So I was imagining like, I know that that cop car had to slam on its brakes right after it went past our window. There's nothing there.
There's nothing there. Well, I have a few background catches. At 12 seconds, did anyone else catch that Toby has an adorable coffee mug on his desk that is a candle? I don't understand. How can it be a mug and a candle? Because Jenna, the candle is in the mug. It's so cute.
What? The candle is in the mug. I took a picture. Is it a functioning coffee mug or a functioning candle? No, it's a functioning candle. I don't understand. Oh my God. I'm going to show you.
I feel confused. Look at it. It's so cute. What a cute gift. Okay. It's a coffee mug candle. Oh, I get it now. Okay.
So it looks like a white diner coffee mug, but the mug is filled with wax and has a wick coming out of it. Okay. I like it. Now I want it. Now you want it. I have another background catch. I'm going to call it Kinsey busted.
What is that? At one minute, three seconds, I am behind Pam next to Creed. Then I am standing and reaching towards John, passing him something behind everyone's back. Hmm. Busted. In the next frame, I am seated. What's going on? Yeah.
What is going on? I was passing something to John. You're all over the place. I'm all over the place. And then I have an overall, what I called a what the heck moment. Okay. Which we've discussed, which is, where's Topi? Yeah.
Did you get a fan mail flurry about that? I didn't. What? Not a single letter. Nothing. I was so sorry. I'm so sorry. Ella B from Ontario did mention it.
Well Ella, you and I were clearly thinking the same thing. Where the heck is Topi? I did look at the call sheet. Thanks to James Carey. I mentioned, and there was a person listed as the Scranton Strangler on the call sheet. Who? Who? It was one of the precision drivers who was driving the Scranton Strangler's car.
We almost solved the mystery of the Scranton Strangler. I know. We were so close. Yeah. But on the call sheet, it says police driver number one, police driver number two, police driver number three, Scranton Strangler. That's what it said. Well the episode is going to start with Michael walking through the office at kind of a brisk
clip and Erin is like scurrying behind him. She wants to invite him to Gabe's party. There was an alt beginning to this. It's in deleted scenes where Gabe is passing out the invites to his party. Oh. He gives one to Stanley and Stanley's reaction was so funny to it, Jenna. I wanted you guys to hear it. Crossword clue.
Ten letters means time of your life. Gabe's party. Well, look at this. Thank you for thinking of me. Why the hell? I got my own crazy idea for tonight. I'm going to watch a TV show. I want to watch with people.
I want to watch it with NCIS by myself. It was really funny. He's talking head. He had the invite in his hand and he's like holding it up like, are you kidding me? I did zoom in on the invite. Okay. It was a pink invite with purple writing looked very festive. It said the party was taking place Tuesday at 7 p.m. and it has a make your own pizza
bar. Hmm. Michael starts out by pretending like he doesn't have time for TV shows. He's never heard of Glee. He's walking in a circle and then it's a prank. He does know what Glee is and he'd be happy to be there. Erin has a talking head where she basically says she's really glad Michael's coming. She's not sure if Michael likes Gabe very much.
And then she talks about the Glee mashups where they mash up two songs that don't really go together to make a really great song. Do you remember how big those mashups were that Glee would do? People loved them. Yes. I looked it up. Glee did 43 mashups in total. And there are websites that rank them like what's the best mashup?
It looks like for the most part everyone agrees that the best one was the thriller heads will roll mashup. Oh, please tell me you have a clip. I want to hear it. I have a clip and it's pretty amazing and I wish you could see the visuals because it's like the football team on the field and they all look like they're from Thriller. Oh, cool. It was great.
Here's the clip. There you go. That's so cool. It's so catchy. They all are. I watched many, many of them to prepare for this episode. I'll tell you what, if I could sing like that, I'd be trouble. Oh, yeah?
Mm-hmm. It's like something I would love to be able to belt out a tune like that. I'd have so much sass in me, I'd be a sassy singer. You would? Mm-hmm. Well, if you were on Glee, I would be a full on Gleek for you. Thank you. You're welcome.
Well, you know, there was a deleted Michael Talking Head where he shared his thoughts on Gabe. There's part of this Talking Head that made me laugh so hard. I rewound it and rewatched it again. I just want you to hear this part. I don't really know Gabe. I know that whenever I hear his name or see him, I am surprised and then I remember who he is.
The story that made me laugh, it just cracked me up. Whenever I hear his name or see him, I'm surprised. Who is this guy? Oh, yeah. Like every time. Oh, that's pretty amazing. Well, Kelly has a pretty great Talking Head where she gives all her thoughts on Glee. Oh, yeah.
We got a fan question from Abigail R. in Niceville, Florida, who said, I feel like Kelly's opinion on the plot of Glee is actually Mindy's opinion. Is that accurate? I think there's a good chance of that. Uh-huh. Right. Blurring of the line there. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We've got a little Dwayangela in the kitchen. We do. Angela wants to know if Dwight's going to go to the viewing party. Mm-hmm. Dwight said not because I want to, with all the feeling to base a show around Glee, thirst. Now that's a show I'd watch.
You know, there was a show called Thirsty. What was it about? Here's their logline. What does modern courtship, sex, and love look like between damaged individuals? Oh, my God, this is horrible. Thirsty. Oh, no. Yeah.
It was a comedy. Oh. It came out. I thought it was a reality show for a minute. No. And I got really nervous. No. No.
No. It was a scripted show. I think it came out in 2020. It was, um, might have just been a pilot episode. I didn't see a number of other episodes, but there are lots and lots of movies called Thirst. I mean, Dwight and Angela could have a real, you know, movie night around the word thirst if they wanted.
If they wanted. All I could think about in this moment was the fact that Creed, a few years ago, insisted that Josh and I watch alone. He was like, you got to see it. You got to see it. And now we're like hooked on a loan and Creed was like, it makes you look at animals different, huh? Why?
Like you're going to eat them? Because you're like, they're starving. They've got to eat. And Josh was like, yeah, totally. No. And like you look at a squirrel differently. Oh, my goodness. Well, Aaron is going to extend an invite to Andy and it's a little awkward.
They're so awkward. The two of them are so awkward. Yeah. I mean, obviously Andy doesn't want to spend an evening in Gabe's apartment watching him be a couple with Aaron, but he can't say no. He says he'll be there. This moves us to the kitchen and really one of my favorite looks from Oscar at four minutes and 29 seconds.
I don't know if you noticed it in the background. Is it when Kevin refers to Gabe as the boss? Yes. It's so amazing. So like you have Daryl and Oscar and they're making sandwiches on the kitchen counter. And then Kevin makes this faux pas of referring to Gabe as Michael's boss. Yeah. And he's like, backpedal, backpedal.
Yeah. And then when Michael goes to ask Daryl and Oscar's opinion about this, they're gone. They've exited. There is a tiny moment before that where over Michael's shoulder, you just see Oscar clock what's going on. And it's perfect. It is so, so good. We're going to travel now to Gabe's apartment.
It's the evening. Aaron is giving Michael a tour. She's so enamored with Gabe's apartment. It's like a fancy grown up apartment. There's big wine glasses, Jenna. Very large wine glasses. Which Phyllis is going to enjoy. I had a fun background catch at this entrance moment at four minutes and 45 seconds.
You start by seeing an exterior shot of the building and you hear a door close. And then it cuts to Aaron and Michael and the apartment door is already closed. It says if they'd entered, but that way we didn't have to show what was behind the door. You will see what's behind the door at the end though. Movie magic. So Gabe is going to walk Michael through all the toppings for the make your own pizza bar. There's a really fun thing in deleted scenes, Jenna. What is it?
Michael wants his own ingredients for the pizza. He doesn't like all of these amazing ingredients that Gabe has laid out so nicely. He goes into Gabe's pantry and he picks out spaghetti-os. And Gabe says, I was saving that for one of the children I mentor. I remember shooting this. Yeah. So I remember because I was, I remember being worried for Steve. So Michael makes a pizza with spaghetti-os as the topping and he takes this huge bite.
I remember this. Yes. Steve had to take a huge bite out of this pizza topped with spaghetti-os. It looks so disgusting. I thought he was going to gag. And then as Michael, he spits it out into the trash. It looks so nasty. It led me down a pizza rabbit hole.
That's a pizza rabbit hole. Pizza rabbit hole is, and I barely scratched the surface. But here are a few things I found about how people eat pizza around the world. What are they? Let's start with Australia. There is a Aussie pizza that is topped with barbecue sauce. That's the base. Yep.
Mozzarella, cheese, little bits of chopped bacon, sometimes ham, and a few eggs. Whoa. And the last one surprised me. What about barbecue sauce though? No tomato sauce. Well, I often eat a like barbecue chicken pizza. Oh, well there you go. And it's very good.
So why was I so surprised by barbecue sauce? I don't know, but I would eat that Australian pizza. With the egg on it? I would. Okay. Would you eat this one? In Russia, there is a popular pizza known as the makba, if I'm saying that correctly. It contains the following sardines, tuna, mackerel, salmon, onions, and it's traditionally
served cold. No. Pass on makba. Finland has a funny pizza topping story. They have a pizza called Pizza Berlusconi, and I'll tell you how this pizza came about. I guess there was an Italian Prime Minister named Silvio Berlusconi, and he made a jab at Finnish cuisine. He said the Finnish food usually consists of marinated reindeer.
Well, guess what the Finnish did? Did they put marinated reindeer on a pizza? They named a pizza after him, and they included a bunch of Finnish stereotypical food, including smoked reindeer, mushrooms, and red onions. And this pizza is now served in restaurants across the country, and is called the pizza Berlusconi. I would try it. I might feel bad about eating reindeer because it makes me think of Rudolph, but I guess
I'd try it. I think I would try it. Okay. Here's just a fun tidbit, a pizza tidbit. Every pizza in Sweden is served with pizza salad. It's a tangy coleslaw salad with red pepper. Some people eat it as a side, others eat it on top of the pizza. I would eat that, and I would put it on top of my pizza.
Okay. California Pizza Kitchen does a pizza, they do a BLT pizza, and there's kind of a salad on top of it. It's really good. Quick pizza fun fact, Norwegians are said to consume the most pizza per capita in the world. Not America? Norwegians.
What? I know. New Yorkers. You're letting us down. I know. Lastly, according to the internet, Korea might be the most adventurous pizza makers out there. Basically, anything goes.
Toppings on pizzas can range from kimchi to snails, potatoes, t-bone steak, and calamari. Some pizzas even have stuffed crust. But guess what it's stuffed with? What? Sweet potato. Oh. Hmm. There you have it, guys.
That's just scratching the surface. There's a lot of pizza content out there. I want you to know. Have you ever had a St. Louis style pizza, Ange? I really wish I'd brought one in today because it's so on theme. No. I've never had St. Louis style pizza. What is that?
Okay. We have a pizza place. It's called Emo's Pizza. They're most famous for serving the St. Louis style pizza, but other places do it as well in St. Louis. It's a very, very thin crust, and it's crispy. Ooh, I love thin crust. Ooh, I love that.
So when you bite it, it's crispy. Ooh. But the topping is sort of a cheesy sauce that then hardens into a kind of a plastic. Plastic? Plastic. This isn't selling it. Well, it's made out of a made-up cheese called Provelle. So it's...
It's not real cheese? No. It's in sort of the Velvita category. Okay. You know, it's a processed kind of made-up cheese. Okay. So St. Louis style pizza, and then you put the other traditional toppings on, sausage, pepperoni, whatever you want, but it's the crispy, crispy crust with this Provelle cheese
on top. And BJ Novak went to St. Louis to do some stand-up, and he was like, tell me about your local cuisine. Where should I go? Yeah. And I said, oh, you have to get toasted ravioli. You have to probably go get some Ted Drews frozen custard, and then you've got to try a St. Louis-style emo's pizza.
Still to this day, he gives me trouble about this pizza. Anybody who's not local St. Louis does not appreciate this pizza. It's interesting. He talked to me when he was filming in New Orleans, and I told him where to go to get good gumbo. Oh, yeah. He's really cool. He likes to eat like the local cuisine when he goes places, but oh, shoot, what a missed
opportunity. I could be eating some emo's pizza right now. I'd be so happy about it. Well, next up, Michael's going to have this talking head where he's kind of, I don't know, he's going on and on about how Gabe likes to entertain versus how he likes to spend an evening. It was total sad sack. He just has like a bag of steamed vegetables from the microwave and a sangria.
Yeah. Well, we had a really fun fan catch from MR in Hoboken, New Jersey, who said, I noticed that in the background of Michael's talking head at Gabe's apartment, you can see Oscar out of focus, and he's doing what looks like charades. It starts around five minutes and 17 seconds, and I think he's acting out the film back to the future. No way. Yeah.
Emma watched it a couple of times just to be sure. He only does the first two words, but it really does seem like that's what it might be. I checked it out and he does. Oscar does the charade for movie four words, first word, back, and then he does second word, and then he does like the number two, but then it cuts off. Was that in the script? It was not in the script.
This was just some amazing background performing that we came up with on the day, but it's really fun to watch. Well, Michael is going to insist on tossing his own pizza dough, and there was a blooper. You know, my daughter loves the bloopers. Oh, yeah. And she watched this episode with me and she goes, oh, mom, mom, there's this great blooper where Steve is tossing the pizza dough and it flies up and lands on the boom operator's mic.
Yes. And so we went and watched it. It cracked me up. Michael, who's doing the boom for this scene, and he got a microphone full of pizza dough. Randy sent us a really cool video of them testing out this pizza dough hitting the fan bit. Yeah. And it was really cool.
You see all these guys, all our crew guys, like just in the warehouse throwing pizza dough at a fan to see like, where does it go when it hits the land? Like, how fast should the fan be going? It was cool. Gabe is going to welcome Pam and Jim into his man cave. We find out he spent his senior year abroad in Japan. And also he loves to play some soundscapes on the keyboard. Yes.
We had a fan catch from Halsey in the UK who said, Gabe said he spent his year in Japan, yet for the rest of the episode, everything in his room is from China. Hmm. Good catch, Hal. Nice catch. Yes. Also in this scene, you know, Cece is awake. It's evening.
She's reverse cycling. Yes. She's up all night, which means Pam's up all night. We got a lot of mail. Did we really? Yeah. I want to hear it. First of all, from Andrea D and Chattanooga, Tennessee, why does Pam get upset about Cece
waking up at night when she has her out at a party with the lights on? Oh. Caitlyn A from Westfield, New Jersey says, as a mom of three babies under two and a half, if your baby is reverse cycling or having any type of sleep issue that's causing stress to your family, why would you bring said baby to an evening party? We got some fan mail sass. We did. Basically, people said they didn't understand the logic.
If she didn't care, they could understand why she brought Cece, but if she's stressed out about it, stay home. Yeah. And then people wondered, is it because it was her boss's party? Did she feel obligated to come? And so, yeah. I sort of think if it were me, I would have welcomed the excuse to stay home and just have Jim represent us at the party.
如果她不在乎，大家就能理解她为什么带西西来，但如果她为此压力很大，那就待在家里。是的。然后大家就在想，是不是因为这是她老板的派对？她觉得有义务来吗？所以，是的。我有点觉得，如果换作我，我会很乐意借此机会待在家里，只让吉姆代表我们去派对。
Yeah. Here's the amazing thing. When you become a parent, you have an instant out that is acceptable and lean into it. If your friend is like, oh, you guys, please come over. I'm going to try different fondues. And you're just like, I don't want to go over there and try a bunch of fondues tonight. You're like, you know what? We're actually getting the baby down earlier.
是的。这里有个神奇的事情。当你成为父母时，你立刻就拥有了一个被大家接受的借口，并且可以顺势利用它。如果你的朋友说，哦，天哪，你们来吧。我要尝试做几种不同的火锅。而你其实只是不想去那儿尝一堆火锅，你就会说，你知道吗？我们其实要早点哄宝宝睡觉。
I should probably stay home. There's always... Yes. We're introducing a new sleep routine and it's not great timing. Or as they get older, you're like, you know, it's school night, so there's just so many ways to lean into the acceptable parent, I can't make it excuse. This is our advice. Have children so you have an excuse not to go to things.
我大概得待在家里。总会有……是的。我们正在引入新的睡眠习惯，现在时间不太合适。或者等他们大一点了，你会想，你知道的，今天是上学前一晚，所以有很多方法可以顺理成章地用“我是个父母，我去不了”这个借口。这就是我们的建议。生个孩子，这样你就有借口不参加各种活动了。
So you have an excuse not to be social. Well, the show is starting. Erin gathers everyone in the living room. Let's watch Glee. I could have watched Kelly and Phyllis on that couch all night. I know. Their dynamic was cracking me up. Phyllis is driving Kelly crazy, asking her all these questions.
这样你就有借口不用社交了。好吧，节目开始了。艾琳把大家聚在客厅里。我们看《欢乐合唱团》吧。我能在那个沙发上看着凯利和菲莉丝一整晚。我懂。她们俩的互动快把我笑死了。菲莉丝一直问凯利各种问题，把凯利逼疯了。
Well then, Oscar starts annoying her because he keeps pausing to discuss and she's got a great sass line. She says, oh, I'm sorry, is this a Glee watching party or a Glee pausing party? I'm with Kelly. I agree. Don't keep pausing it to chat me up and if you're going to come to a viewing party, know the show. Phyllis.
然后，奥斯卡开始惹恼她，因为他不停地暂停来讨论，而她有一句超赞的毒舌台词。她说，哦，不好意思，这是《欢乐合唱团》观影派对还是《欢乐合唱团》暂停派对？我支持凯利。我赞同。别为了跟我聊天一直按暂停，如果你要来参加观影派对，就了解一下节目。菲莉丝。
Oh boy. Michael is in rare, rare Michael mode. He's acting like a bratty kid. He's going to say, hey, I'm going to have my own Glee watching party in the bedroom, where we can crank up the volume and he tries to recruit people to Gabe's bedroom. Yeah. But the only person who's there is Pam, who's trying desperately to get Cece to go to sleep. In fact, in the next scene, when Gabe is showing Ryan all of his stuff, his stereo from the
天哪。迈克尔进入了一种极其罕见的迈克尔模式。他表现得像个任性的小孩。他说，嘿，我要在卧室里举办我自己的《欢乐合唱团》观影派对，我们可以把音量调到最大，他试图拉拢大家去盖比的卧室。是的。但唯一在那里的人是帕姆，她正拼命想让西西睡着。事实上，在下一个镜头中，当盖比向瑞恩展示他的所有藏品时，他的立体声音响来自
1970s and his five Chinese virility herbs, you can see Pam at eight minutes and 34 seconds in the background, still holding Cece's carrier, rocking it back and forth. By the way, there was a baby in that carrier. Oh, that's heavy then. I know. But you know what? Babies were sometimes lighter than the jelly babies. I think they were always lighter than the jelly baby.
20世纪70年代，还有他的五种中国壮阳草药，你可以在背景中看到帕姆在八分三十四秒的时候，依然拿着西西的婴儿提篮，前后摇晃着。顺便说一句，那个提篮里真的有个婴儿。哦，那挺重的。我知道。但你知道吗？婴儿有时比软糖娃娃还要轻。我觉得它们总是比软糖娃娃轻。
Yeah. We are going to learn that one of the virility herbs Gabe has is powdered seahorse. And apparently they say that 15 Chinese soldiers fought off the entire army of Genghis Khan, just using the powdered seahorse. We got a fan question from Abigail R. in Niceville, Florida. Please tell us everything about the Chinese virility herbs. Oh, get ready. Abigail, I will.
是的。我们将了解到盖比拥有的其中一种壮阳草药是海马粉。据说有15个中国士兵仅仅利用海马粉就击退了成吉思汗的整支军队。我们收到了来自佛罗里达州尼斯维尔的阿比盖尔·R的粉丝提问。请给我们详细讲讲中国的壮阳草药。哦，准备好吧。阿比盖尔，我会的。
Abigail, should I tell you what Jenna texted me when she went down this rabbit hole? I'm going on my phone. This is what happens when you search. These virility herbs, wait, wait, just that phrase brings up a lot. Abigail, here's the text Jenna sent me after researching the Chinese virility herbs. Hey, Ange, working on viewing party. I decided to Google five Chinese virility herbs. It's mostly websites with photos of giant dicks trying to sell you but her herbs.
阿比盖尔，我该告诉你詹娜在我深入了解这个冷门知识时发给我什么短信吗？我要拿手机了。当你搜索时就会这样。这些壮阳草药，等等，等等，光是这个词组就搜出了很多内容。阿比盖尔，这是詹娜研究了中国壮阳草药后发给我的短信。嘿，安吉，正在准备观影派对。我决定用谷歌搜索“五种中国壮阳草药”。结果大部分都是挂着巨型丁丁照片、试图向你兜售草药的网站。
Oh my God. I've seen so many dicks today. Oh my gosh. It's true. It's really true. Oh man. But here is what I learned. Minus all the picks.
哦天哪。我今天看到了好多丁丁。哦天哪。真的。千真万确。哦天呐。但这是我了解到的。去掉了所有的图片。
Yeah. These herbs, particularly dried crushed seahorses, are believed to have Viagra-like powers, meaning that they're mainly used to treat erectile dysfunction. But they're also believed to give the body more energy and they can also prevent premature ejaculation. These are the claims. They are also sometimes used in a tea to treat asthma, but here's the thing. According to the director of the School of Chinese Medicine at the University of Hong
是的。这些草药，特别是风干压碎的海马，被认为具有类似伟哥的功效，这意味着它们主要用于治疗勃起功能障碍。但它们也被认为能给身体提供更多能量，还能防止早泄。这些都是宣传的功效。它们有时也被用来泡茶治疗哮喘，但关键是。根据香港大学中医药学院院长2019年的说法
Kong in 2019, there is not any scientific evidence that consuming dried crushed seahorses will do any of these things, and there have been literally no clinical trials carried out on humans that examine these results. Yeah, thank you. In addition, Sarah Foster, who is the program manager of Protect Seahorse at the University of British Columbia in Canada, said about 37 million seahorses are caught wild every year because people think that they should dry them and eat them, and seahorses have dropped by 30% and 50% in the past 15 years.
香港在2019年表示，没有任何科学证据表明食用风干压碎的海马能起到上述任何作用，而且实际上也没有在人类身上进行过任何检验这些结果的临床试验。是的，谢谢。此外，加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省“保护海马”项目的项目经理莎拉·福斯特表示，由于人们认为应该把海马晒干吃掉，每年大约有3700万只野生海马被捕获，在过去15年中，海马数量下降了30%到50%。
In response to this, Thailand and the Philippines and Indonesia have banned the export of seahorses, but there's a lot of smuggling that still occurs. But you know, Sarah Foster would really like you to stop eating the crushed seahorses. I'm with Sarah Foster. When I was a kid in Indonesia, we'd go out to the Thousand Islands, and when the tide would go out and there'd be little tide pools, you could walk out pretty far between the islands and you would often see a little seahorse in a tide pool, hanging out on some seaweed. That sounds magical.
作为回应，泰国、菲律宾和印度尼西亚已经禁止出口海马，但仍有大量走私活动发生。不过，你知道的，莎拉·福斯特真的很希望大家停止食用压碎的海马。我支持莎拉·福斯特。当我小时候在印尼时，我们会去千岛群岛，当退潮时会有小潮池，你可以走到岛屿之间很远的地方，你经常会在潮池里看到一只小海马，挂在一些海草上。听起来太神奇了。
It was magical, and I was a child, and that was a magical memory for me. Stop eating seahorses. They don't help your penis. They don't. Let them live and thrive, and then maybe there can be less pics on the internet, too. Oh my gosh. Dwight is going to join Pam and Michael in the other glee-viewing party room. And he's really annoyed that other people aren't coming over, but what really starts
这很神奇，而我当时是个孩子，那对我的来说是一段神奇的记忆。别再吃海马了。它们对你们的阴茎没帮助。真的没有。让它们活着并繁衍生息，也许这样互联网上的丁丁照片也能少一些。哦天哪。德怀特将加入帕姆和迈克尔所在的另一个《欢乐合唱团》观影派对房间。他对其他人没有过来感到非常恼火，但真正开始
to annoy him is Pam's crying baby. Yeah. Did you see, though, I was doing the bounce move? I did. I didn't even have a kid yet, and I felt like I was doing a killer bounce move. We got a lot of fan mail from people who noticed that the baby in this episode looked very different from last week's baby from the christening. That is because it is a different baby.
惹恼他的是帕姆哭闹的婴儿。是的。不过你们看没看到，我在做那个弹跳动作？我看到了。我当时甚至还没生过孩子，我觉得自己做出了一个超赞的弹跳动作。我们收到了很多粉丝的来信，他们注意到这一集里的婴儿看起来和上一集受洗礼的那集里的婴儿非常不同。那是因为那确实是一个不同的婴儿。
This baby's name was Violet. I noticed it right away. Yes. The babies who had been playing CC were Bailey and Sienna, and they were there, but they would not fuss. Aw. Yeah. You know, Bailey and Sienna were just really chill babies.
这个婴儿的名字叫维奥莱特。我一下子就注意到了。是的。之前扮演西西的婴儿是贝利和谢娜，她们也在现场，但她们就是不肯哭闹。啊。是的。你知道的，贝利和谢娜真的是那种非常淡定的婴儿。
I think they had also gotten very used to you being on our set, and Violet was new to all of it maybe, and it just was more unsettling. Yes. That's right. Well, Dwight is going to pick up baby CC and instantly comforts her. She completely stops fussing. Lady, that really happened. I was going to say, you can't cheat that.
我想她们也已经非常习惯你出现在我们的片场了，而维奥莱特可能对这一切都很陌生，所以才会更加感到不安。是的。没错。好吧，德怀特抱起了婴儿西西，并立刻安抚了她。她完全停止了哭泣。天哪，那是真的发生过。我本来想说，你没法作假。
There is no movie magic from the moment Rain picks her up. We don't cut away, and the baby stops fussing. I was like, what happened? I wanted to know. It was just real. Well, it was scripted that Dwight would have this magic touch with babies, and we kept saying, how are we going to do that? We got like, what if it doesn't work?
从雷恩抱起她的那一刻起，没有任何电影特效。我们没有切镜头，婴儿就停止了哭泣。当时我就想，发生什么了？我很想知道。那完全是真实的。好吧，剧本里写的就是德怀特对婴儿有这种神奇的魔力，我们一直说，我们要怎么拍呢？我们想，万一不管用怎么办？
What if the baby keeps fussing? So we had this whole plan where we're going to have Violet who is fussing, and then Dwight will take her, and then we'll cut away to a different baby somehow in editing. The first take, Rain walks over to me. He picks up Violet, she immediately stops fussing in his arms. Oh my gosh. And it happened every single take. She loved him.
万一婴儿一直哭闹怎么办？所以我们有整个计划，让正在哭闹的维奥莱特出场，然后德怀特抱起她，接着我们在剪辑时切到另一个婴儿。第一条，雷恩朝我走来。他抱起维奥莱特，她在他怀里立刻停止了哭泣。哦天哪。而且每次拍摄都是这样。她喜欢他。
She loved him. He was a natural. She completely calmed down in his arms every time. And we were just like, this is amazing. That is so wild. Rain had a special touch with the baby. Well, the fact that Dwight is the baby whisperer is the best news Pam has had in a long time. Oh yeah.
她喜欢他。他是个天才。每次在她怀里她都完全平静下来。我们当时就想，这太神奇了。太疯狂了。雷恩对婴儿有一种特殊的触感。好吧，德怀特是婴儿语者，这是帕姆很长时间以来听到过的最好的消息。哦，是的。
She won't let him put baby CC down. Yeah. She's like, CC can sleep. I'm going to get my life back. Yeah. And Dwight is like, you know what? I don't need to hold the baby all night. Here's what you need to do.
她不让德怀特放下婴儿西西。是的。她就像是在说，西西可以睡觉了。我要重新过上我自己的生活了。是的。而德怀特则说，你知道吗？我不需要整晚抱着婴儿。你需要做的是
You just need to go to Gabe's fridge, get any suet or congealed animal fat, tie a piece of string to it, and then tie the other end to CC's toe and pop the suet in her mouth and she'll be happy for hours. Instantly he's like weirdo Dwight. He went from being like amazing baby whisperer to what, tie it on the toe. What are you talking about? I had to know what is suet. What is suet?
你只需要去盖比的冰箱，拿任何牛脂或凝固的动物脂肪，在上面系上一根绳子，然后把另一端系在西西的脚趾上，把牛脂塞进她嘴里，她就会开心好几个小时。他瞬间又变成了那个怪咖德怀特。他从一个神奇的婴儿语者变成了，什么，把它系在脚趾上。你在说什么。我必须弄清楚什么是牛脂。什么是牛脂？
It is the raw hard fat of beef, lamb, or mutton found in the loins or the kidneys. Yum. But here's why I thought I had heard of it before. Great British baking show. Do they use suet? They use suet. Oh. Because it is an ingredient in many British recipes like their Christmas puddings and
它是牛、羔羊或绵羊腰部或肾脏里的生硬脂肪。听起来挺香。但这就是为什么我觉得我以前听说过它。英国烘焙大赛。他们用牛脂吗？他们用牛脂。哦。因为它许多英国食谱中的一种原料，比如他们的圣诞布丁和
pastry. This week is Patisserie Week. We'll be going home with Nigel. Nigel lives with his mom in Devonshire. I love this. They'll be making orange marmalade biscuits. That's right. I love great British bake off.
糕点。本周是法式糕点周。我们将和奈杰尔一起回家。奈杰尔和他的妈妈住在德文郡。我太喜欢这个了。他们要做橙子果酱饼干。没错。我喜欢英国烘焙大赛。
Well the common American substitute is shortening, like Crisco, but it's the sort of thing where like if you use suet in your pie crust, it's really good if you're making like a meat pie or it has a wet filling and then you want to use butter for a sweet pie. This is like when you come to my mom's house and you try her cornbread and you're like, Birdie, why is your cornbread so good? And she's like, first you get some bacon, put it in your skillet, you're going to cook that bacon. Yes.
常见的美国替代品是起酥油，比如克里斯科（Crisco），但这种东西，如果你在派皮里用牛脂，如果你在做肉派或者有湿馅的派时会非常好吃，然后如果你要做甜派的话你想用黄油。这就好像你来到我妈妈家，尝尝她做的玉米面包，然后你会说，伯蒂，为什么你的玉米面包这么好吃？然后她说，首先你拿一些培根，把它放进平底锅里，你要把培根煎熟。是的。
Then take the bacon out but leave the grease in there. Then you put it in your mix. That's right. That's similar. Now I want my mom's cornbread. Well, maybe we should take a break because when we come back, Darryl is going to get a little tour of the man cave and Andy's going to do something really dumb. Oh, Andy.
然后把培根拿出来，但把油脂留在里面。接着你把它倒进面糊里。没错。这差不多。现在我想吃我妈妈做的玉米面包了。好吧，也许我们该休息一下，因为等我们回来后，达里尔将参观一下男人的专属洞穴，而安迪会做一件非常蠢的事。哦，安迪。
Sarah Foster would not be pleased. No. We are back and like we said before the break, Andy's going to make an unfortunate decision. He pours the dried seahorse into his red wine and chugs it, like all of it. Yeah. This is going to turn out bad for Andy. But meanwhile in the living room, during a commercial break for Glee, Jim decided to change the channel to get kind of a sports update.
莎拉·福斯特不会高兴的。没有。我们回来了，正如我们在休息前所说的那样，安迪将做一个不幸的决定。他把干海马倒进红酒里，然后一口气喝光了，全喝下去了。是的。这对安迪来说结果不会好。但与此同时在客厅里，在《欢乐合唱团》的商业广告期间，吉姆决定换台看点体育新闻。
What's happening? But guess what happens when he turns the channel back? Erin wasn't recording. So it jumped ahead. And Kelly's very upset because they missed a huge performance. Lady, do you remember when Steve and Nancy invited us all over to watch the Oscars at their house? I can't, and Nancy, like this happened.
发生什么事了？但你猜他把频道调回去时发生了什么？艾琳没有录制。所以它跳过了。凯利非常难过，因为他们错过了一场精彩的表演。天哪，你还记得史蒂夫和南希邀请我们所有人去他们家看奥斯卡颁奖典礼吗？我记不得了，南希，就像这样发生了。
I remember now that you're saying it, I remember it. It was literally the last award of the night. It was like the best movie of the year and all of a sudden it jumped ahead and we missed the final moments and we were like, what, what just happened? And then Nancy was like, oh no. Yeah. And we had to look it up. Yeah.
经你这么一说我想起来了，我记起来了。那真的是当晚的最后一个奖项。就像是年度最佳电影，突然之间画面跳过了，我们错过了最后的时刻，当时我们就在想，什么，刚刚发生了什么？然后南希就说，哦不。是的。我们不得不去查了一下。是的。
We missed the final speech. It was so funny. We all started crafting up. Yes. I remember that. I really enjoyed the scene with Andy and Phyllis. So much. She smells like white diamonds.
我们错过了最后的演讲。太搞笑了。我们都开始哈哈大笑。是的。我记得那个。我非常喜欢安迪和菲莉丝的那场戏。太喜欢了。她闻起来有白钻石香水的味道。
Wow, you really know your perfume. And then he says his nanny used to wear that. Yeah. He's acting weird. This is just the beginning of Andy's strange behavior and a little bit he's going to walk up to Erin faking a phone call to UPS. Yeah. He's waiting on the five minutes with Erin he ordered.
哇，你真的很懂香水。然后他说他保姆以前喷过这个。对啊。他表现得很诡异。这只是安迪怪异行为的开始，过一会儿他就要走向艾琳，假装给UPS打电话。对啊。他在等他要求的跟艾琳相处的五分钟。
But then he starts to get sick. I need to point out something in this scene. It is how brilliant Ed Helms is. Look, I know that there's a lot of serious awards out there for dramatic performances and comedic performances, but I would like to introduce a new category to the Emmys called best about to puke scene because it's really hard to do and he sells it so well. And it made me laugh every time. I think we need to hear it.
但接着他开始觉得不舒服。我得指出这场戏里的一个亮点。那就是埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）的演技有多绝。听着，我知道有很多针对戏剧表演和喜剧表演的严肃奖项，但我想在艾美奖里设立一个新奖项，叫“最佳快要吐了”场景，因为这真的很难演，而他演得太到位了。每次都把我逗笑。我觉得我们得听听这段。
Oh, you having a good time? Did you wear my favorite outfit on purpose? You look awful. You're four seasons in a day. You got the autumn thing going on. But if you put on baby, but if you put on a blue, it's freaking hot. I mean, it makes me start to like gag when I hear him doing it. It's so visceral.
哦，你今天过得挺开心？你穿成这样是故意让我看你最喜欢的衣服吗？你看起来真糟糕。你这一天经历了四季。你这身打扮完全是秋天的感觉。但如果你穿上宝贝，但如果你穿上蓝色，那就太火辣了。我是说，听到他这么说，我简直开始犯呕了。太有代入感了。
So good. It's so hard to do and really sell it and he did such a great job. He did. I would like that to be a category please the next award show. While that's going on, Gabe and Michael are attempting to make pizza dogs and Erin enters and it's so clear that she just really wants Michael to like Gabe. Yeah. She needs Michael's approval on this guy and it is not going to happen.
太棒了。这太难演了而且要演得逼真，他真的做得太好了。确实。我希望下次颁奖典礼能把这设为一个奖项。与此同时，盖布和迈克尔正试图制作披萨热狗，艾琳走了进来，很明显她真的很想让迈克尔喜欢盖布。对啊。她需要迈克尔对这家伙的认可，但这根本不会发生。
No. In fact, it doesn't go well and Michael ends up storming out of the whole apartment. I know. Jim and Angela are now going to find Dwight and Pam in the bedroom. Cece is still loving Dwight and guess who is completely turned on by that? Yeah. Well, Angela whispers in his ear outside in her car two minutes. It's on.
没错。事实上，事情进展很不顺利，迈克尔最后气冲冲地走出了整个公寓。我知道。吉姆和安吉拉现在要去卧室找德怀特和潘。西西还是很喜欢德怀特，你猜谁被这个完全激起了欲望？对啊。嗯，安吉拉在车外他耳边低语，两分钟。开始了。
It's on. Someone wants a baby. But Pam is like, you cannot leave. You cannot go. It's so awkward too because Jim and Pam are like stuck there is Dwight and Angela have this weird conversation about their punch card, sex card, so awkward. Well it gets more awkward because of all the things that Dwight makes Jim do in order for him to stay.
开始了。有人想要个孩子。但潘却说，你不能离开。你不能走。这也太尴尬了，因为吉姆和潘就像被困在那里一样，而德怀特和安吉拉还在讨论他们那个奇怪的积分卡、性爱卡，太尴尬了。嗯，情况变得更尴尬了，因为德怀特为了让他留下来，让吉姆做了各种各样的事。
Dwight makes Jim feed him a piece of pizza. Crust first. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Do you eat your pizza crust first? How do you eat your pizza? I hold the crust as it was meant to be done. That's the handle, right?
德怀特让吉姆喂他一块披萨。从饼皮开始。哦，对啊。哦，对啊。你吃披萨是从饼皮开始吗？你是怎么吃披萨的？我拿着饼皮，本来就该这样。那是把手，对吧？
It's the handle. It's your bread handle that you then get to eat at the end and maybe if you have some ranch dressing, you dip it in there. Well according to an article on marthastewart.com, oh Martha, what you got? Here's how people eat their pizza. Okay. So 28% of people eat their pizza tip to crust. Only 28% eat it, how we're saying, but your pizza handle.
那是把手。那是你的面包把手，你最后可以把它吃掉，或许如果你有牧场沙拉酱，还可以蘸着吃。好吧，根据marthastewart.com上的一篇文章，哦，玛莎，你有什么料？大家是这样吃披萨的。好吧。有28%的人吃披萨是从尖端吃到饼皮。只有28%的人是像我们说的那样吃，但那是你的披萨把手。
It's not very much. Also, it's a term I never knew that I needed to know, but now I know it, tip to crust. 18% eat it crust first. Come on. Then how's everyone else eating it? 17% fold it in half. That's a calzone people. 14% sandwich two slices together and eat it like a pizza sandwich, 14%.
占比其实不高。另外，这是一个我以前从不知道、但现在觉得有必要知道的词，从尖端到饼皮。18%的人从饼皮开始吃。拜托。那其他人都是怎么吃的？17%的人把它对折。那是卡尔佐内馅饼，各位。14%的人把两块披萨叠在一起，像吃披萨三明治那样吃，14%。
I respect that. 8% eat it with a knife and fork. No. So dignified. I don't know. But watching Jim feed Dwight this pizza and Reigns chewing, it was a lot. It was a lot. And then also he made him like gently pour beer into his mouth.
我尊重这一点。8%的人用刀叉吃。不。太讲究了。我不知道。但看着吉姆喂德怀特吃披萨，还有雷恩斯在咀嚼，这信息量太大了。信息量真大。然后他还让他把啤酒轻轻倒进他嘴里。
It was all, it was very, this sound. It was so gross. I'm sorry. I apologize for making the sound. It was gross. But someone needs to go out and talk to Angela. And Dwight says to Pam, she is in heat and she will eat your face off. Well, Pam's going to go.
这整个过程，这声音。太恶心了。对不起。我为发出这个声音道歉。太恶心了。但总得有人出去跟安吉拉谈谈。德怀特对潘说，她正在发情，会把你的脸撕下来。好吧，潘要去了。
She has no choice. She has to keep Dwight there. Pam goes. And Angela, I remember shooting this with you. Jenna, I was going to say the same thing. I remember every beat of this, everything. Well, it was one of those scenes with just the two of us. It wasn't a scene with us and then people in the background.
她没别的选择。她得把德怀特留在那儿。潘去了。安吉拉，我记得和你一起拍这场戏。珍娜，我也正想这么说。我记得每一个节拍，所有的一切。嗯，这是只有我们俩的场景之一。这不是那种我们和背景群众演员一起的戏。
It was just us. It was late at night. We were the last scene of the day. Yeah. I remember it so clearly. Same. But what were you wearing? Because it looks like you're wearing nothing.
只有我们。当时很晚了。我们是一天中最后的一场戏。对啊。我记得太清楚了。我也是。但你当时穿的是什么？因为看起来你好像什么都没穿。
Well, no. I had on like a, like a spandex strapless nude like thing. What do you call it? Like a Bando. Is it a Bando? No, I don't know. I don't know. A bustier?
嗯，没有。我穿着那种无肩带的肉色氨纶紧身衣。那叫什么来着？就像抹胸。是抹胸吗？不，我不知道。我不知道。紧身胸衣？
No, a bustier kind of pushes everything up and out. Yeah. This was just like a nude like undergarment. Right. I mean, and jeans. I had on like jeans because you couldn't see. I was shocked when I watched the scene that Angela had undressed already. She was ready.
不，紧身胸衣那种会把所有东西都托起来往外送。嗯。这只是像肉色的内衣。对吧。我是说，还有牛仔裤。我当时穿着牛仔裤，因为你看不到。当我看到这一幕时，我惊呆了，安吉拉竟然已经脱好衣服了。她准备好了。
Yeah. Her man is quieting a baby. Yeah. She skits Angela's clothes off clearly. Yeah. Do you know what I noticed that I didn't think about when we were filming it and then I watched it and it cracked me up. In true Angela fashion, she asked Pam her advice and then doesn't like what Pam says
对啊。她的男人在哄孩子。对啊。她利落地把安吉拉的衣服扒了。对啊。你知道我注意到什么了吗？拍的时候我没多想，后来我看节目的时候笑死我了。符合安吉拉一贯的作风，她先向潘征求意见，然后又不喜欢潘说的话，
and then is mad. Right? Yeah. And then she hits the button and the window slowly goes up, which led me to think she's been sitting in a running car. Oh yeah. She's in the back seat of a running car. Oh, that's such a good observation.
接着就生气了。对吧？对啊。然后她按了按钮，车窗缓缓升起，这让我觉得她其实一直坐在开着发动机的车里。哦，对啊。她在一辆开着发动机的车后座里。哦，这观察力太敏锐了。
I didn't notice that. I didn't clock it. Well also outside is Michael, who was messing with the cable box. Yeah. He like unplugged everything. The TV goes off. People are really upset. I would like to point out a continuity moment at 17 minutes, 57 seconds.
我都没注意到。我完全没察觉。另外外面还有迈克尔，他正在摆弄有线电视盒。对啊。他把所有插头都拔了。电视熄灭了。大家都很生气。我想指出一个在17分57秒的穿帮镜头。
Kevin yells, you can hear him in the background. He's like, what's going on? But he was in a bedroom eating pigs in a blanket in a blanket. Oh, you're right. Uh-huh. Yeah, he's in two places at one. His magic, Kevin. He wasn't yelling from the bedroom.
凯文在大喊，你能在背景音里听到他。他说，怎么回事？但他当时明明在卧室里用毯子裹着吃猪肉卷。哦，你说得对。呃-huh。对啊，他同时出现在两个地方。他是魔法凯文。他可不是从卧室里大喊的。
Was he? The cable went out. Could he still be in the blanket? Eating pigs in a blanket? They didn't have a TV on in there. Oh, they did have a TV on in there. Yeah. Okay.
是吗？电视线断了。难道他就不能还在毯子里吗？吃着猪肉卷？他们那里面又没开电视。哦，他们里面确实开着电视。对啊。好吧。
Well then my theory doesn't work. Forget it. He's not magic, Kevin. He's just loud, Kevin. Yeah, I guess so. Michael pretends like he doesn't know what's going on. You know what I love? Creed gets off the phone and tells everyone like what happened.
那我的理论不成立了。算了吧。他不是魔法凯文。他只是声音很大的凯文。好吧，我想也是。迈克尔假装自己不知道发生了什么。你知道我最喜欢什么吗？克里德打完电话，把发生的事告诉了所有人。
I know. Michael says he has an idea of how to fix it. He doesn't know if it'll work, but he'll try. So he's a saboteur and then he's going to be the hero. I guess that was his whole plan. And then Michael and Aaron have the scene outside that is so sweet and heartbreaking and funny and tender and odd because, you know, they kind of have this odd dynamic. When Michael realizes he's hurt Aaron's feelings by saying, you know, I'm not your dad.
我知道。迈克尔说他有个主意能修好它。他不知道行不行，但他会试试。所以他先当了破坏者，然后又要当英雄。我猜这就是他的整个计划。然后迈克尔和艾琳在外面有场戏，非常甜蜜、心碎、搞笑、温柔又有点古怪，因为，你知道的，他们之间有一种奇特的化学反应。当迈克尔意识到自己说“我不是你爸”伤害了艾琳的感情时，
Then he leans into it and he's like, go to your room and she's like, I won't go to my room. She like so quickly gets on board and it's really sweet. We had a fan question from Bennett C in Jersey City, New Jersey who said, Aaron confronting Michael as he's fixing the cable box is one of the most powerful moments of the entire series. Oh, when she says she cares if Michael likes Gabe and he responds, why I'm not your father. Ellie does not have a follow up line, but in the next few seconds you can see Aaron's
然后他顺着这个梗说下去，就像个父亲一样说，回你房间去，而她却说，我才不回房间。她入戏太快了，真的很甜。我们收到了来自新泽西州泽西市的贝内特·C（Bennett C）的一个粉丝提问，他说，艾琳在迈克尔修理电视盒时与他对峙，是整部剧中最震撼的时刻之一。哦，当她说她在乎迈克尔是否喜欢盖布，而迈克尔回答说，为什么在乎，我又不是你爸。艾莉没有接话，但在接下来的几秒钟里，你能看到艾琳的
entire life story move across her face and eyes. It's an amazing scene. And then Wyatt D from Kentucky said this scene with Michael and Aaron in particular is incredibly tender and genuine and really exemplifies the role Michael plays in Aaron's life. This really touched people and me too. This was the thing about our show where, you know, we cast these people who we're always just going to for the comedy moment. And so when they dig deep and give this dramatic performance that's based in this real kind
整个人生经历从她的脸庞和眼神中闪过。这真是一场精彩的戏。然后来自肯塔基州的怀亚特·D（Wyatt D）说，迈克尔和艾琳的这场戏格外温柔真挚，真正体现了迈克尔在艾琳生命中所扮演的角色。这真的触动了很多人，也触动了我。这就是我们节目的特色，你知道的，我们选角找来的这些人，我们总是让他们去负责搞笑。所以当他们深入挖掘，展现出这种基于真实心碎的戏剧表演时，
of heartbreak, you know, Brian Baumgartner does it as Kevin and then Ellie does it as Aaron, it just, wow, it just, it takes you by surprise. And it grounds the show. It's one of my favorite things about our show. We say it all the time, but it is. So many characters over the course of the nine seasons have a moment like this and it's always so powerful. And of course, Ellie and Steve just crushed it.
你知道的，布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）作为凯文时做到了，然后艾莉作为艾琳时也做到了，真是，哇，真的会让你感到意外。而且它让整部剧有了现实基础。这是我最喜欢我们节目的地方之一。我们经常这么说，但事实确实如此。在九季的过程中，很多角色都有过这样的时刻，而且总是那么震撼。当然，艾莉和史蒂夫演得太棒了。
But you know, as much as Aaron needs Michael to be her father, Michael just wants a daughter. So it's very sweet. Yeah. Well, and when Michael's saying goodbye to Gabe at the door, he says, I'll kill you if you hurt Aaron. And it's a figure of speech, but he will literally kill him and his entire family. And then he says, that girl's going to turn my hair gray. Mm-hmm.
但你知道，尽管艾琳需要迈克尔当她的父亲，迈克尔只是想要一个女儿。所以这非常甜蜜。嗯，当迈克尔在门口和盖布告别时，他说，如果你敢伤害艾琳，我就杀了你。虽然这只是一种修辞手法，但他真的会杀了盖布和他的全家。然后他说，那个女孩要把我的头发急白了。嗯哼。
Yeah, it's really sweet. You know what we haven't mentioned? What's that? Is the fact that Andy puked on a maid bed in Gabe's house and covered it with a pillow. Gabe is going to find that. That's so gross. And then Andy's going to end up throwing up at a toilet as Gabe rubs his back. And Gabe's like, you know what we need right now?
对啊，真的很甜。你知道我们还没提到什么吗？什么？就是安迪在盖布家的铺好的客房床上吐了，还用枕头盖住了。盖布迟早会发现的。太恶心了。然后安迪最后在马桶旁吐，而盖布在一旁帮他揉背。盖布还说，你知道我们现在需要什么吗？
Yeah, we need a little soundscape. Mm-hmm. Yeah, he's going to get out his keyboard. He's going to start playing Earthrise on the moon. This was an original piece of music. Our editor, Claire Scanlon, had a friend named Roddy Bottom, who composed this song just for us and we licensed it for $500. Well, I really think we need to hear that as we end this episode, but before we do,
对啊，我们需要一点背景音乐。嗯哼。对啊，他要拿出他的键盘了。他要开始演奏《月球上的地球升起》。这是一首原创音乐。我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦（Claire Scanlon）有个朋友叫罗迪·博特姆（Roddy Bottom），这首歌是他专门为我们创作的，我们花500美元买下了版权。嗯，我觉得在我们结束这集节目之前，我们真的得听听这首歌，但在我们这么做之前，
that was viewing party. There it was. A big thank you to Randy Cordray and James Carey for helping us get lots of fun tidbits for this one. And to you guys for listening and sending in your questions and comments. And now you guys, here is Gabe's Earthrise on the moon. Have a great week. Bye.
那是观剧派对。就是这样。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）和詹姆斯·凯里（James Carey）帮我们为这一集搜集了那么多有趣的幕后花絮。也谢谢你们收听并发送你们的问题和评论。现在各位，这就是盖布的《月球上的地球升起》。祝大家有个美好的一周。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西共同制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾因斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。